[Musik]
wie es unbekannten amerika präsentiert
das wissen wo es noch ein flug ausfällt
[Musik]
hast du eine kettensäge
dann kann ich das hier auseinander sagt
man kettensäge auch spanisch
[Applaus]
donnerstag arena
euro
[Applaus]
[Musik]
mein name ist arthur honegger acht jahre
lang waren die usa mein zuhause als
korrespondent bin ich in dieser zeit
ganz schön rumgekommen 47 von 50
bundesstaaten habe ich besucht und auch
heute noch beschäftigt mich dieses große
verrückte land praktisch nonstop bei
meiner fernseharbeit in dieser serie
will ich nun ein unbekanntes amerika
entdecken
abseits der großen politik neue starten
neue menschen neue erfahrungen
[Musik]
in puerto rico gibt es ein davor und ein
danach
vor september 2017 die vorherigen maria
und danach
neun monate ist der sturm her hat sich
meinen fuß zum ersten mal auf die insel
setze ich bin mit lisa ladner verabredet
sie lebt seit zwei jahren hier ist halb
puerto ricanerin und halb schweizerin
dieser ist schweizer honorarkonsulin in
puerto rico kennt sich aus weiß auch wo
ich mit anpacken kann beim wiederaufbau
denn die wunden die der sturm diesem
paradies zugefügt hat sind längst nicht
verheilt
wirklich in schockstarre
[Musik]
ricoh ist ein territorium der usa in der
karibik hurrikan mariam tötete über 3000
menschen und zerstörte unzählige häuser
ein sturm der kategorie 5 weiter geht
die scala gar nicht
[Musik]
die vorgaben ohne strom
es gibt immer noch sehr viel
es geht immer nur improvisiert mit einer
plastik
[Musik]
dieses wertes sturm graz den überquert
rücken
wir wollen nicht einfach über die misere
berichten
wir wollen mit anpacken mal sehen wie
weit wir in einer woche kommen
das kinder und jugendtheater florida
karriere zog früher mit dieser fahrbaren
bühne durch die dörfer der insel seit
ein paar jahren hat es auch einen festen
platz
hier in louisa jetzt ist alles zerstört
[Musik]
das
die dame die kommen im kulturzentrum von
luisa sora moreno hat das theater vor 36
jahren gegründet es ist ihr lebenswerk
das hier in trümmern liegt
doch bereit den kopf guten tag mein name
ist julia ich bin die bürgermeisterin
dieser wunder wünscht hat das war der
raum wo wir geprobt haben
theater tanz wohl eher passiv lauf noch
brandgefährlich
[Musik]
150 kinder und jugendliche haben hier
getanzt und gelacht musik und theater
gemacht
dann kam der sturm
[Musik]
wenn so etwas passiert dann geht das
ganz tief in mir drin brennt anfange
junge menschen zu unterstützen
ich bin selbst den armen verhältnissen
aufgewachsen und so ist es das bedürfnis
entstand bin mich zu bilden nicht nur
für mich selbst sondern auch für andere
damit ich ihnen etwas anbieten kann
die kinder sollen die möglichkeit haben
aufzusteigen und ihr glück zu finden
siehe da so da hat sogar eine kostprobe
ihres schaffens für uns vorbereitet
das ist mein herz
[Musik]
denn
so da erzählt mir theater sei der erste
ort auf der insel gewesen und dem
schwarze kinder ins bett gehen konnten
[Applaus]
dass jetzt die bürgermeisterin hier ist
hat wohl nicht zuletzt auch mit unserer
kamera zu tun
was braucht es hier damit dass wieder
aufgebaut werden können
wir brauchen geld
wir haben 737 häuser mit blauem
plastikbechern
[Musik]
das ist im moment unsere priorität
die leute braucht man da von meinem kopf
wir werden hier etwas geld geben aber es
reicht nicht wir sind eine arme gemeinde
das theater hat eine große bedeutung
ja wir haben probleme mit dem
zusammenhalt
er hat einen großen beitrag geleistet
dass beziehungen unter den kindern aus
verschiedenen milieus entstehen
sie macht wichtige sozialarbeit
du bist nicht allein wir sind bei dir
ich glaube dir
solche versprechen hat so dass schon
öfter gehört
vielleicht folge mehr mit unserer
anwesenheit jetzt auch taten
die bürgermeisterin jedenfalls wenn
morgen gemeindearbeiter schicken
ob sie auch geld bereitstellt da bin ich
mal gespannt
[Musik]
heute passiert hier aber gar nichts mehr
es ist nämlich sonntag zeit für den
gottesdienst
auch davis oder verbündete suchen und
wir kommen mit auf dem weg zur kirche
beginne ich zu verstehen warum bord rico
sich die insel des charmes nennt das
fleisch und
[Musik]
jährlich kommt direkt aus lüge
aber das so und wenn 36 es passt auch
sehr typisch sind mit trinks sie
behandeln lassen
die zsc lions cocktailpartys dafür ist
batterie co bekannt
maria hat aber auch den tourismus schwer
beschädigt er hat sich bis heute nicht
ganz erholt
immerhin der historische kern der
hauptstadt san juan wird seiner
glanzvollen geschichte gerecht und
kollegen auch wieder kreuzfahrtschiffe
an
sie bringen die touristen zurück die
dieses stück weltkulturerbe mit eigenen
augen sehen wollen
[Musik]
columbus besetzte die insel einst im
namen der spanischen krone erst ende des
19 jahrhunderts wurde die kolonie teil
der usa irgendwie denn puerto rico ist
kein eigener bundesstaat sondern ein
assoziiertes territorium
das bedeutet dass die prärie karner zwar
einen us pass haben aber nicht
mitbestimmen können wer im kongress oder
im weißen haus sitzt er ist der pastor
dieser kirche sprechen sie spanisch
englisch ich bin aber
sie sehen aus wie george clooney ich bin
nicht der erste der faktor das ist zu
viel der ehre
wir haben karibische musik freu mich
drauf
[Musik]
für die die mich nicht kennen ich bin so
moreno
ich bin seit 26 jahren in durch ohne im
quartier santiago meine tochter luisa
ist in dieser kirche getauft worden
diese gruppe von freunden aus der
schweiz ist hier hergekommen weil das
kulturzentrum von luisa vorherigen real
zerstört worden ist
wenn ihr jemanden kennt der helfen kann
wir machen alles für luise
[Musik]
damit bin ich jetzt bekannt wie ein
bunter und ihr ein kulturzentrum muss
wirklich was gehen
die hoffnung jedenfalls ist mit händen
zu greifen oder besser gesagt mit armen
zu umschließen man herzt sich hier ja
[Musik]
und man kocht für einander immer genug
versteht sich
die traditionelle küche ist ein
mischmasch der kulturen indianisch
afrikanisch spanisch kommt alles
zusammen amerikanisch sind hier heute
nur die hygienevorschriften
[Musik]
und dann lerne ich noch ein weiteres
theater talent aus so das ensemble
kennen den kleinen alex grundschule ist
der hauptdarsteller eines stückes der
broadway wartet das stück quanto hat
sora moreno geschrieben
vor mehr als 30 jahren es ist auf der
ganzen insel bekannt wann die ist die
mutter von alex sie erzählt mir dass das
stück rund um brannte und seiner familie
nicht gerade wieder sehr aktuell ist
das thema des stückes der vater hat kein
geld findet keinen job
es gibt kein auskommen hat er
entscheidet sich in die usa zu gehen
weil er verwandte hat
die kinder bleiben bei den großeltern
zurück mit dem wirbelsturm marie er ich
das heute wieder eine ähnliche situation
weil für die leute nach dem strom weg
bringen
viele familien möchten gar nicht weg
aber sie müssen sie lassen alles zurück
um in die usa zu gehen
heute leben 3,3 millionen amerikaner in
ihrer heimat in den usa leben weit über
fünf millionen
die wirtschaft auf der insel liegt
allerdings nicht erst seit dem hurrikan
am boden vor maria kam der finanz sturm
und jetzt ist pleite oft lässt sich
nicht genau sagen was die häuser hier
mehr beschädigt hat die naturkatastrophe
oder die misswirtschaft
nicht wenige sehen die schuld auch in
washington
der zugang zu den handelshäfen etwa ist
nur amerikanischen frachter gestartet
steuergeschenke für großkonzerne waren
jahrzehntelang üblich um seit ein paar
jahren kontrollieren die usa sogar das
budget vollständig ich merke schnell
der streit über den status von pepsico
ist das politische thema hier
[Musik]
montagmorgen die arbeit ruft wir wollen
eine abkürzung zum theater nehmen und
ich lerne abseits der hauptstraße wird
sehr schnell mal abenteuerlich aber
diese wasser auf der straße ein
rohrbruch vielleicht eine folge des
sturms vielleicht einfach nur zufall
eine infrastruktur so genau weiß das
niemand her
speck vereinbart
also groß war ein sehr guter start jetzt
[Applaus]
ich hab den wichtigsten teil haben
jedoch nicht verpasst auf einer
baustelle das heißt im kreis stehen und
besprechen was gemacht werden muss
ganz wichtig
ein halbes dutzend arbeiter steht bereit
die bürgermeisterin hat wort gehalten
diese sachen hier also weg ich spreche
kein englisch
sehr guten tag gehören sie auch zum
theater
ich habe das team von der stadt her
gebracht
vielen dank dass sie hier sind
[Musik]
tanzen stadt im kreis stehen hier geht
es anders zu und her als auf
europäischen baustellen so viel ist
schon mal platz kann ich da draußen was
machen willst du anfangen
ja ich möchte anfangen
[Applaus]
sie können machen was sie wollen
wir wollen nur helfen wo können wir
helfen
er kann einfach weitermachen irgendwas
muss man hier tun
[Applaus]
alles gewachsen er seit dem hurricane
tja dann taucht zum glück david auf ein
freund von so einer der weiß was zu tun
ist das merke ich sofort
[Applaus]
es ist wie patron also das ganze
sperrholz kommt raus ja alles perfekt
[Applaus]
zum dritten woche monate so verbrachten
sie not exactly how traum auf neun
monate lang stand hier die zeit stellen
jetzt kommt bewegung in die sache
unsere ankunft acta offenbar etwas
ausgelöst
[Musik]
doch sie service
foto miedl
[Musik]
da ist dabei neben den sohn david und
den arbeitern sind auch freiwillige vor
ort leute die im theater gearbeitet
haben und jugendliche die hier auf der
bühne standen zusammen arbeiten wir am
neuanfang
ich probier s mal mit englisch und du
willst mich adoptieren ist das für deine
familie ok meine mutter ist vielleicht
froh wenn du mich eher abnimmt
dabei weiß nicht mal was das heißt
langsam
[Musik]
maria konnte ich drei wochen lang nicht
mit meiner familie sprechen
ich hatte keinen kontakt zu meinen vater
meine mutter oder mein bruder also
bewusst ist nicht wo sie waren
nein die telefonmasten waren weg
schrecklich du warst damals in
windstarken ja ich habe dort gearbeitet
aber deine familie ging es gut nach dem
sturm
und woher kennst du so wir sind aus
demselben quartieren ich kenne sogar
seit meiner kindheit david als junger
mann treppe rico verließ um in den usa
als schreiner zu arbeiten hat air bühnen
will der versorger gemacht jetzt mit 58
ist er zurück auf der insel um sich um
seine eltern zu kümmern
[Musik]
jetzt sieht anders aus als gestern oder
hast du glücklich ich bin sehe ich bin
überrascht was wir in einem tag alles
geschafft haben und ich bin sehr dankbar
für eure arbeit wenn man bedenkt dass
ihr von der schweiz hierher kommt so
große karriere um uns zu helfen und zu
motivieren und schlägt damit dass die
distanz keine rolle spielt wir sind ein
es gibt nur einen planeten
wir sind alle noch viel arbeit viel
arbeit
manchmal ist der staat das wichtigste
es ist der vierte juli der
nationalfeiertag an dem die usa ihre
unabhängigkeit von der britischen krone
feiern für mich eine gute gelegenheit
mehr über das verhältnis der preppy
ricaner zu den vereinigten staaten zu
erfahren
also beach statt baustelle heute
wir sind aus der schweiz
wir machen einen dokumentarfilm will
ver.di den vierten juli gut ganz toll
und was macht an den strand gehen können
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
wie geht es euch vor und vierter juli
mit trainern dokumentar werden woher
kommt ihr auf der schweiz
was denkt ihr dass das auch ein feiertag
ist warum nicht wir sind ein territorium
kein staat
[Musik]
ich bin stolz us amerikaner zu sein
ich habe in zwei kriegen gekämpft ja ich
bin stolz amerikaner zu sein aber ich
bin auch stolz puerto ricaner zusammen
wir sind ein zwischending anstatt
dazwischen zu sein wäre mir ein stark
leber also der 51
dann kann ich entscheiden wer präsident
wird entweder ein staat oder unabhängig
aber nicht die situation jetzt danke mal
gut mit euch zu reden
70 was das heißen soll darüber gehen die
meinungen auseinander
die vorstellungen reichen von kompletter
integration als bundesstaat der usa
bis zur vollständigen unabhängigkeit
schon mehrmals wurde darüber abgestimmt
zuletzt 20 16
da war die mehrheit für den bundesstaat
folgen haben solche voten allerdings
keine die zukunft von trikot wird in
washington bestimmt und dort besteht
derzeit wenig interesse den status quo
zu ändern
schließlich würde jede veränderung auch
einen kontrollverlust bedeuten
kein feuerwerk am himmel über samra am
us nationalfeiertag
was wie ein politisches statement wirkt
es den wahrheit aber nur ein weiteres
zeichen dafür will er die kassen hier
sind super was hältst du davon würden
wir gleich jetzt ins rathaus kommen um
dich und die bürgermeisterin zu treffen
eigentlich die höhere schule sind
griechische verhältnisse ich jetzt
unterstellt das heißt jetzt sage ich
kein raubbau kriegt so da nun das
versprochene geld von der
bürgermeisterin oder rettet das theater
weiter hingehalten
das ist die große frage heute
sogar beim start ich bin zufrieden wir
können zum baumarkt gehen und uns das
material schicken lassen
wir haben grünes licht tatsächlich die
bürgermeisterin hat so oder 4500 dollar
zugesagt bedanken können wir uns gleich
persönlich denn jeden morgen um 9 fährt
ein wagen mit lautsprecher vors rathaus
und die chefin trip ans fenster um voll
die stadt hymne zu singen
[Musik]
ist diese
danke für das theater tag 4 auf der
baustelle
[Musik]
heute sind ein paar jugendliche dazu
gekommen die mithelfen
sie alle standen auch mal auf der bühne
hier der hurricane hat das gebäude von
der versorgung abgeschnitten haben nun
aber geht es auch da vorwärts das team
kümmert sich um die kaputte
wasserleitung
[Applaus]
sollen wir das wasser testen
wir haben das auto repariert was das
werde ich sehen
auch alex der den kleinen grant show
gespielt hat kommt heute auf die
baustelle
wie fühlst du dich wenn sie das theater
so siehst
es ist unglaublich was die natur
anrichten kann muss man es immer wieder
aufbauen
noch stärker auf das muss man du musst
dich selbst ein besseres leben geben
[Applaus]
du weißt schon viele
[Musik]
wird der kleine zurückkommen wenn das
theater wieder schlägt ja das ist die
idee manchmal ist geld nicht alles
manchmal braucht man eine helfen der
liebende hand das möchte ich ihnen
beibringen
das ist eine gute lektion die die mutter
von alex lebte ebenfalls ein paar jahre
in den usa und hat sich dann wieder
entschieden
ist das gut dass du sowohl hier als auch
in den staaten leben kannst ja wir haben
das beste aus beiden welten
ich kann in puerto rico leben aber ich
habe trotzdem die freiheit jederzeit in
die usa zu gehen und dort mein glück zu
suchen
in den usa kämpft aber niemand an seine
tür und sagt ich helfe dir hier in
puerto rico ist es etwas einfacher sich
irgendwie durchzuwursteln das mag ich
nicht so in den usa muss man hart
arbeiten um überleben zu können nicht
erwarten dass andere einem helfen sicher
nicht doch er ist nur eine person
wir sind mehr er kann noch 50 jahre im
amt sein wir sind größer
die usa und puerto rico werden nicht
wegen donald trump untergehen
eine positive einstellung
stichwort trump er hat sich aufbrachte
rico wenig freunde gemacht nach dem
sturm
die hilfe lief nur zögerlich an
erst nach fast zwei wochen kam der
präsident selber auf die insel und warf
um seine hilfsbereitschaft zu
unterstreichen haushalts papier in die
menge
[Musik]
ein schlag ins gesicht für die menschen
hier besonders auch für die
bürgermeisterin von sun fun die damals
klare worte fand
[Musik]
mrs
diese frau muss sich kennenlernen
im schlagabtausch mit jump machte
germanier ihn international bekannt
das time magazine zentis jeder nach zu
den 100 einflussreichsten personen der
welt sie sprechen vom ich sie kennen zu
lernen
ich bin der schweizer gutes land gute
leute gute schokolade
danke dass sie sich zeit nehmen
tolle augen kam im juli möchte unseren
park 2 in den sie renovieren ließ ihr
paradeprojekt in san juan
ja solar betriebene mini bus geht es
darum erstmal auf rundfahrt mit einer
bürgermeisterin zum anfassen die wir
schnell merken wie schafft man halo auf
deutsch
die 40
[Musik]
mehr hey nah neh
danke dass sie für uns kämpfen das werde
ich immer ich kämpfe sie schlagen mich
und ich kämpfe weiter
etwas vom wichtigsten im park ist unser
gewechselt alle angestellten hier sind
schwere autisten
wir wollen eine gesellschaft bilden in
der jeder etwas beitragen kann
es spielt keine rolle ob du nur etwas
kannst wie zb samenpflanzen man merkt es
mir nicht an aber ich bin
legasthenikerin darum trage ich diese
armbänder
als ich klein war bemerkte meine
kindergärtnerin dass ich leicht verwirrt
wurde die band mir ein gummiband und die
rechte hand damit ich meine rechte von
meiner linken unterscheiden konnte
mittlerweile hat jedes band eine
bedeutung dieses hier bekam ich als
auszeichnung dafür dass sich wahrheiten
ausspreche ist das zu glauben
dafür gibt es nur aus zeichen wenn man
jemanden dafür auszeichnen muss die
wahrheit zu sagen
ich meine das hat schon etwas über
unsere politische klasse oder ich frage
die dinge gerne auf
[Musik]
mit mir geht sie locker um aber nicht
washington
sie spricht jenen amerikanern aus der
seele die sich im stich gelassen fühlen
sie sagten dass politiker wie bürger
zweiter klasse
nun wir sind eine kolonie der usa wir
tragen fesseln und sind indessen nicht
einmal bewusst
ich glaube das nennt man stockholm
syndrom
du merkst gar nicht dass du keine
eigenständigen entscheidungen treffen
kannst es gibt einen aufsichtsgremium
das jetzt über den kopf von puerto ricos
gouverneur finanzentscheider film manche
denken dass wir uns in einem machtkampf
befinden
ich denke dass nicht ich weiß wer an der
macht ist und dass sie nicht wir was wir
brauchen ist ein richtiger
demokratischer dialog okay sagt uns usa
was braucht es damit ihr uns einen
bundesstaat gibt was damit ihr uns
unabhängigkeit geht was für ein freies
bündnis mit doppelter staatsbürgerschaft
oder für eine erweiterung des heutigen
status
lasst die bürger entscheiden
eine frau ohne berührungsängste und ohne
angst vor großmächten von dieser
politikerin wird man denke ich noch
hören sie überlegt sich ins rennen zu
steigen für ein nationales an
es ist tag auf der baustelle
[Musik]
schöner wohnen in das material wird
geliefert das soda mit dem geld der
gemeinde gekauft hat das hier werden die
bretter sein die die welt bedeuten für
viele kleine tänzerinnen in louisa wir
beeilen uns denn für morgen schon hat
sogar eine erste kleine vorstellung
geplant als abschiedsfest für uns
[Musik]
aus
und weil ich jetzt mehr als einmal dazu
aufgefordert wurde
frage ich mich noch auf die
traditionellen stelzen der stelzenläufer
der so genannte variante ist eine
zentrale figur in puerto ricos folklore
sodass tochter rosi zeigt mir wie es
geht
ich erkläre dir was du tun musst du
musst deine beine stabil halten und was
passiert bin ich runter dafür gibt es
techniken aber du wirst nicht fallen
du kannst dich zum balancieren am gitter
festhalten jede menge vertrauen wenn du
das dann kann ich da laufen
jetzt laufe ich zu retten
du musst hier ist gut und zudem machst
du das zum ersten mal
er ist ja es ist nicht geboten und
skateboarden braucht auch viel balance
[Musik]
st
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich ahne es morgen muss ich wohl auch
auf die bühne
das kann ja heiter werden
67 infos und sehen
[Musik]
katharina
weißt du was toll ist eine batterie
kommt überall musik überall
jeder bringt seine eigene musik und
zusammen ergibt das dann diesen
speziellen sound man kann die stadt
sehen wie sollen wir hin
david hat die ganze woche fast pausenlos
gearbeitet
zum abschluss lade ich ihn auf ein
feierabendbier 1
ich mache das weil ich so reilly
sie ist wie meine schwester wenn sie
mich braucht bin ich da denkst du du
gehst jemand zurück in die staaten
ich denke nicht vielleicht gehe ich mal
auf besuch
meine tochter und mein enkel leben in
georgia ich möchte hier bleiben
es reicht ich bin müde vom herumreisen
ich liebe meine inseln das ist mein
paradies
man könnte meinen riss der sturm alles
zerstört hat er hat auch viel zerstört
aber nicht den geist
[Musik]
die energie hier beeindruckt mich
irgendwie trotzig weitermachen auch wenn
so viel in trümmern liegt
mit diesem gedanken mache ich auch von
meinem letzten tag auf der insel
wir haben viel geschafft auf der
baustelle das dach ist zwar noch nicht
wieder ganz aber der boden ist gelegt
und der ist beim tanzen ja das
wichtigste
[Musik]
bis zur letzten davis oder alles um die
bühne herauszuputzen
die strapazen der letzten tage aber
haben spuren hinterlassen
auf der einen seite bin ich sehr dankbar
und zufrieden weil wir viel erreicht
haben andererseits wenn ich weniger sage
dann meine ich weniger ich fühle mich
auch etwas im stich gelassen von den
leuten die gesagt haben dass sie kommen
ist kaum jemand aufgetaucht trotzdem hat
sodann auch die energie in gams luisa
herum zu fahren um kinder für den
heutigen auftritt einzusammeln
[Musik]
wie viel hast du jetzt 45 das sind sehr
gute schauspielerinnen und tänzerinnen
auch ein profi welche karte macht sich
bereit bei dem kann ich mir ja
vielleicht noch ein paar tricks
abschauen
[Musik]
die aufführung heute ist eine exklusive
kostprobe von dem was die kinder hier
alles gelernt haben
zum auftakt sehen wir gleich einen
typisch amerikanischen tanz zwischen
betroffenen und tanzen
das heißt sie die bewegung vor und er
muss reagieren weil er mal keine antwort
mehr hatte für diesen vortrag ist ja
durchaus auch stadt waren sie immer nach
und plötzlich verliert dann hat sie
verloren
[Musik]
echt beeindruckend was die kleinen hier
schauen können
jetzt verstehe ich auch dass so das
theater mehr ist als ein sozialprojekt
es ist ein lebendiges stück lokaler
kultur
[Musik]
dieser rhythmus wirkt wie ein
musikalischer magnet da tanzen dann auch
schweizer füße mit
[Musik]
und ja sie stellten
davor kann ich mich jetzt nicht drücken
[Musik]
ich bin schon etwas aufgeregt aber auch
das ist eine erfahrung
[Musik]
ich spüre wie wichtig es den menschen
hier war das nach maria auch eine andere
seite von mario gezeigt wird wie die
insel wieder auf die beine kommt monate
später erhalte ich eine erfreuliche
nachricht
lisa leitner hat eine schweizer stiftung
gefunden die dem theater unter die arme
greift und von recaro so eine zukunft
des unbekannten america präsentiert
wurde von swiss für türen wo es noch ein
flug ausfällt
[Musik]